Sports Illustrated Swimsuit models will
be at the first-ever summer of swim fan
festival and concert taking place this
Sunday that will be at Coney Island
Beach and boardwalk in New York City
Hannah Ferguson and other swimsuit
models will make appearances they'll be
there there's an SI cover photo booth
there they got a whole lot more there at
si.com slash swimsuit and hannah joins
us here in the man cave is a little cold
for you little but it's ok you sure that
yeah cuz Pauly's got a sweater if you'd
like to be draped in the sweater um I'll
get back to you on that I'm good right
now
after that catwalk I think got the heat
going a little bit oh whoa uhh
McLovin did a catwalk for Hannah yeah
but and fritzy did one that was a little
bit better fritz ease wrap was a little
bit better when you say it was on point
yeah yeah as far as McLovin oh I could
walk I can do a model walk but do you do
can't walk stuff uh not generally but
I'm hoping to ok hopefully this season
is that a learned skill you know what
you would think that walking would just
come naturally but actually walking in
heels in front of everybody you know the
heels tend to be kind of wobbly and
skinny and hard to walk in and it's
actually pretty tricky but imagine
Giselle at the Olympics in front of
everybody at the opening ceremony with
the girl from Ipanema
well she's walking across the stage
she's a pro she's all like makes it look
so easy but it's not I mean not for me
why she I've seen the catwalk no you
know women they fallin like yeah there's
a like a compilation on YouTube of all
the girls that have fallen before it's
it's kind of embarrassing but it's
actually really funny what are you
surprised I'm not on there what do you
have you fallen no but I haven't really
done that many show so maybe do it on
purpose and then you get famous I know
right that's a good idea yeah go viral
yes and that's what it told they'd have
to be in slow-mo though so you could
watch my Facebook group by the way
that's still a great face even when your
phone
so tell me about this you've been in the
swimsuit issue how many times three
times so this most recent was my third
and where was that Jang I shot in Turks
and Caicos well that's not bad so
beautiful there
now do you bring people with you or you
just go by yourself just me myself than
I oh yeah yeah and then there's a
photographer normally with a1 like he's
a one name photographer did you have
like his like his name is Francisco or
something like that James James Macari
oh oh so that's a different photographer
he's great he's phenomenal what does
pepperoni mean to you I think is that
your favorite question yes your favorite
topic um well it is now now that I know
what it is but I didn't know what it was
it was Chrissy Teigen and Brooklyn
Decker who told me about that
that's that funny um well I mean I
assume you you know what it I think the
updated term is nip-slip now oh that's
not as maintenance I need something
better than that
like pepperoni sounds great it does but
it I think it would just make me think
of pizza and I'd get really hungry
how about popsicle I've never heard that
I'm just awful pretty you got one for
Hanover them your mom - I think popsicle
would be a term that you would use for a
guy if he was wearing a speedo uh Hannah
is going to be at a Coney on who else is
coming there with you do you know yes um
Haley Clausen who is on the cover just
as last year as well as Ashley Graham
who's another cover girl um Hannah Davis
and Samantha hoops so Hannah's now
married she is yeah she's okay
how much competitiveness is there I
don't want to say jealousy or backstab
or backbite I mean I think anybody who
has goals has a bit of competitiveness
in them just because they want to do
well but for me I enjoy getting to know
the girls and seeing their pictures and
you know usually when we're shooting
there's multiple girls that shoot in
each location so well you know
overlapped by a day usually and it's
nice to make friends and have you know
things in common so for me I don't look
at it as competition and I would really
oh yes why well I want to win yeah but
that doesn't mean you have to I don't
know be competitive and nasty to other
people no no not nasty but competitive
and I might I might spread a rumor to
about him but that's not really I mean
that's just the way it works around
that's not me that's not you no no okay
da uh where's the best place you ever
visited to shoot I have to say Turks and
Caicos okay yeah I've always wanted to
go and that was actually my first time
going and it was the best experience
ever and it was totally amazing so
beautiful uh your parents military yes
they were both in the Marine Corps okay
so when the issue comes out the first
time the magazine comes out mm-hmm how's
that go over they're actually very proud
of me and super supportive so um it's
funny because my mom was a drill
instructor so you know growing up was
strict to say the least
um so it's funny cuz you would think
that you have to drop it and like bounce
a quarter off your your bed like was it
had to be made perfectly I mean she we
would have to make our beds but it
wouldn't be you know we wouldn't have to
scrub the deck if we you know if we had
if we had you know mess up or something
so you'd have to peel potatoes or
anything like they do in the military I
mean we peeled potatoes but my mom
always had us involved with everything
like from cooking to cleaning feeding
the animals you know everything that we
did so um buddy you know I think we all
turned out pretty well so who was
tougher your dad or your mom
my mom really yeah oh that did you
didn't my dad - I know also I'm a
daddy's girl and I think he had like a
soft spot for me so what is always the
easier one one of our favorites is
Chrissy Teigen
mhm is is that what people would aspire
to be where she's become more than just
a model yeah she's she's made her a
whole brand for herself your name um I
mean that's what I aspire to have it but
you gotta be risque on social media you
got a comment on social media
I mean she's not afraid to give her a
give an opinion yes she'll definitely
speak her mind she's very outspoken I
admire that I don't I mean I don't think
you have to be risque like you'll have
to be totally out there you can save
some stuff for yourself and your
significant other but um no I think if
you do it the right way and you have you
know a good support system and people
you're working with and you just go for
it and you know being Sports Illustrated
model you have that to back you up so I
think um it's really helped make a name
for me and I'm gonna use that to my
advantage and you know later on in life
build it into something else
do guys that goofy around you right um
it depends sometimes yes if they don't
know that I'm a Sports Illustrated model
people act pretty normal but as soon as
they find out not you guys y'all y'all
know it nobody did they know right now
y'all are cool but the back row acting
goofy soon as they saw ya nervous and
sweaty for a in the morning and is that
attractive nervous and sweaty older guys
is that the thing the move being nervous
is sweating old or being a dork maybe I
don't know dorks are cool yes yes every
time you know you have a pretty woman
and they'll go you know I love I love
someone who's goofy they don't have to
be good-looking well it's kind of like a
sense of humor well it's cause like
cocky guys I think they're all that like
don't find that attract you don't know
well welcome to my group I don't about a
bunch if a guy ignores you mm-hmm
does that work um no I don't know I I
think it's cool when they don't really
care and they're just you know cracking
jokes or saying funny stuff they don't
really care but um you know if you nor
me I'm that's fine I probably won't talk
to you either oh you won't because
McLovin has a philosophy here oh yeah
I'm you probably didn't notice it but
I'm I'm kind of throwing some game your
way I kind of look together is that what
that was
yeah it's the cat and mouse yeah you're
probably fatty who's that dorky guy in
the back row he's sort of a loose
talking to me that was actually pure
nerves but I you know you might
misinterpret that is cool I'm sure some
do listen hey I'm married okay keep you
should've told her that upfront you
should have told her that upfront to be
fair to her
uh Hannah Ferguson will be the swimsuit
models from 2016 first-ever summer of
swim fan festival in concert taking
place this Sunday at the Coney Island
Beach and boardwalk in New York City did
you do a Carl's jr. and I did do it
Carl's jr. yes I was scrubbing a big
black truck and eating a burger
how many Carl's did you eat I think I
took a few bites out of 72 something
like that 72 bites yeah a lot that and
there's a lot of barbecue sauce and oh
no stuff have you had a Carl's jr. since
that commercial shoot um actually I well
it was the next I did cuz I had an
appearance for it and I actually ate a
Carl's jr. sandwich for lunch well
congrats on the success so far thank you
thank you for putting up with us know
y'all are awesome it must be so much fun
like coming to work every day you know
with your best friends right yeah it
sure beats turks and caicos yeah oh by
the way they're showing up some of your
pictures here oh look at that yeah it
was the best shoot I've ever had it I
swear
can you tilt that screen a little Dixie
thirds II can't see the screen terrible
but what do they do they actually say
stuff to you well if I'm your
photographer mm-hmm how do I motivate
you
well my photographer he kind of showed
me some goebbeis of what he wanted to
sort of mimic and the vibe and things
that he was looking for so he doesn't
say something um well he'll say what
looks good and if you want you to change
it he'll let you know but usually we'll
start off with the sort of you know pose
that he may want to mimic or then we
just play around you just kind of go
with the flow and do different things
okay but there's no
something's working he'll say oh great
like yes yes sir
okay I don't know but but give me more
that or yeah exactly
he doesn't say be like a kitten or
something like that no there's nothing
like you like a kitten like yeah like
her me I I was a photographer a tear was
like oh oh crazy one oh yes it is good
like can you do the splits
I was like ah actually yes I think all
right that'll pretty much do it uh you
can go to Sports Illustrated si.com
slash swimsuit for more details about
the fun this Sunday Coney Island Beach
and boardwalk in New York City she's
Hannah Ferguson
thank you stopping by thank you for
having we'll come back right after this
in the Dan Patrick show the Dan Patrick
show weekday mornings on audience